This conference will now be recorded.
Zeichen machen, wenn du das Wort an dich
nehmen willst.
In unserer Homeoffice-Edition.
Wie geht's dir? Ganz gut.
Dir? Ja, durchaus.
Also ich hab mir mein, ich hab's mir hier
einigermaßen gemütlich gemacht.
Ich hab jetzt die erste Woche Homeoffice überlebt und bin noch nicht wahnsinnig
geworden dabei.
Noch nicht Kevin Fieber bekommen?
Naja, also ich habe tatsächlich jetzt überdurchschnittlich viele Pflanzen bei mir zu Hause. Ich habe noch ein paar Blümchen gekauft, um mir so ein bisschen für Stimmung zu sorgen. Mein Kühlschrank war noch nie so voll.
Nicht, dass ich
gebunkert hätte. Ich habe nur
überhaupt mal Lebensmittel gekauft.
Normalerweise habe ich eigentlich fast ausschließlich
auswärts gegessen.
Und jetzt habe ich tatsächlich irgendwie
Brot und Aufstrich
und all den ganzen langweiligen Scheiß, von dem man sich
ernährt. Und ein paar Nudeln.
Du hast noch Nudeln bekommen, du Glückliche.
Naja. Ja, wir nehmen jetzt hier
am Samstag auf, dem ersten Tag
der Ausgangssperre in Dresden.
Hast du das schon gelesen gestern eigentlich?
Ja, war ja ein bisschen überraschend.
Das kam, glaube ich, erst gestern Abend um acht ging es rum.
Ich hatte ja das Produkt bekommen, dass ganz Bayern die Ausgangssperre eingeführt hat,
auch mit Bitternacht, heute Nacht.
Und hatte mit meinen Eltern auch telefoniert.
Und während ich telefoniert hatte, habe ich dann die PDF auch zugeschickt bekommen
von der Allgemeinverfügung der Stadt Dresden.
Das Ähnliches auch bei uns gilt ab 0 Uhr.
Finde ich aber auch noch sinnvoll.
Ich meine, letztendlich ändert sich nichts an der Situation.
jeder bleibt zu Hause, soziale Interaktionen einzuschränken,
so dass man jetzt halt keine sozialen Interaktionen mehr hat mit anderen Leuten,
nicht digital, also hier face to face,
und man darf sich nicht mehr öffentlich treffen.
Aber ansonsten ändert sich ja eigentlich überhaupt nichts, oder?
Naja, also ich hätte eine kleine Party gemacht am Freitag,
aber die ist dann komplett ausgefallen.
Aber die hast du ja vorher schon gestrichen.
Die hatte ich vorher schon aus, wie sagt man, aus Vernunftgründen gestrichen, aber jetzt wäre sie tatsächlich verboten gewesen.
Und ja, ich meine, ich finde es ziemlich krass, wie Schlag auf Schlag das kam.
Also letzten Donnerstag habe ich noch beim Mittagessen mit Kollegen geredet, naja, es wird wahrscheinlich bei uns einigermaßen, ja, es kommt wahrscheinlich bald.
An dem Nachmittag hieß es schon, wir machen jetzt erstmal mindestens zwei Wochen Homeoffice. Bitte kommt maximal Montag noch einmal ins Büro, aber nur wenn ihr unbedingt müsst und danach darf keiner mehr ins Büro.
Also hat die Firma so beschlossen, weltweit alle Büros sind jetzt dicht und das haben sie mittlerweile verlängert auf den gesamten April.
Und dann haben wir uns gedacht, das mit diesen Ausgangssperren, das machen jetzt auch schon ein paar Länder.
Ich frage mich, wann es in Deutschland kommt.
Zack, macht es Bayern und weil Bayern es macht, macht Sachsen es nach.
Zack, macht es auch Sachsen.
Ich hätte ein bisschen Angst, dass Dresden da gar nicht hinterherkommt, beziehungsweise Sachsen selber hat es ja auch nicht.
Es sind ja diverse Bundesländer jetzt.
Ich glaube, bei Bayern, Baden-Württemberg haben mich nicht alles täuscht
und irgendwas nordwestlich war auch noch.
Aber ich weiß nicht mehr genau im Kopf, wer das war.
Hatte vielleicht auch schon eine andere Situation.
Aber Sachsen ja explizit nicht.
Aber finde ich ganz schön, dass Dresden da zumindest mitgeht.
Das ist einfach wirklich vernünftig.
Ja, die Lage in Deutschland ist ja, dass wir mit unseren Bundesländern,
dass da jeder sein eigenes Ding macht, ist irgendwie ein bisschen doof.
Aber es scheint wohl so zu sein, wenn ein Bundesland das vormacht,
machen es dann sehr bald viele nach.
Das ist auch sinnvoll.
Also ich hoffe, dass wir die nächste Folge
nicht mehr unbedingt im Quarantäne-Modus aufnehmen müssen.
Aber mal gucken, was passiert.
Ich finde es ein bisschen weird,
dass das jetzt so als Begriff weltweit etabliert ist
von wegen Quarantäne.
Aber niemand ist hier wirklich in Quarantäne.
Natürlich gibt es Leute in Quarantäne,
aber wir machen alle Social Distancing
und nicht explizite Quarantäne, oder?
Nee, das ist was anderes, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Obwohl der Begriff schon von einigen so verwendet wird.
Es ist zu spät dafür, das zu ändern.
Das ist jetzt Quarantäne, aber ich finde es ein bisschen eigenartig.
Obwohl Social Distancing klingt auch irgendwie,
das klingt fast schlimmer, muss ich sagen.
Social Distancing ist halt,
ich meine, du kannst ja sozial sein,
bloß halt nicht in person.
Du kannst ja trotzdem irgendwie telefonieren
und dich über Videokonferenzen treffen.
Ich war gestern auf einer Konferenz.
Na, erzähl.
Konferenzen, die ab jetzt remote
besuchbar sind
auf absehbare Zeit.
Erst gab es diese wunderschöne, nicht schöne
Seite isitcanceledyet.com
Absolut, habe ich auch gesehen, ja.
Wo dann einfach
überall stand, is it cancelled yet, is it cancelled yet?
Is it
cancelled
yet? Die habe ich
natürlich hier nicht als Bookmark,
weil
ich, weil ich es mit
zwei I getippt,
und es ist mit einem L geschrieben,
oder istitcancelsyet.com
mit einem L,
und da kann man sehr schön durchscrollen
und sieht man lauter
roten Text,
und dann
noch so ein paar Hinweise,
und dann Auflistung von Konferenzen,
Disneyland, yes,
WWDC, yes,
Microsoft Build, yes,
Broadway, the show must not go on, steht da.
March Madness, yes.
The SATs, ah ah.
NBA Season und so weiter und so fort,
da gibt es noch ein paar lustige Sachen zwischendurch,
ich glaube ganz unten, Spoiler ich mal, steht
The Apocalypse.
Es bin cancelled.
Und unten drunter ein Video-Ausschnitt aus Pacific Rim,
wo Idris Elba sagt,
We are cancelling the apocalypse.
Sehr schön.
Fun Fact an der Seite, Idris Elba
wurde mit Coronavirus
diagnostiziert.
Deswegen ist die Apokalypse erstmal aufgeschoben?
Deswegen ist die Apokalypse vielleicht doch
nicht aufgeschoben.
Naja, zumindest
ich würde diese Sektion jetzt relativ
kurz halten. Das Problem ist, dass momentan jedes
Gespräch irgendwie, es ist schlimmer als das Wetter,
sich nur noch um diesen scheiß Virus dreht.
Es ist halt ein weltweites Thema.
Das hat man selten so, dass sich etwas so hart für alle relevant ist
und überall verbreitet und halt auch so hart in unser Leben einschneidet.
Ich meine, selbst wenn es Themen gibt, die weltweit davon relevant sind,
ist es selten was, was uns weltweit dazu zwingt,
daheim zu bleiben und unseren Alltag anzupassen.
Ja, also zum Beispiel, wir nehmen unsere Sendung gerade genauso auf,
wie Stephen Colbert seine Late Show aufnimmt.
Hast du die letzte Folge in das Bild hineingeschaut?
Die fand ich auch sehr witzig.
War das die, wo er vor so einem weißen Hintergrund saß?
Applaus-Schilder angemacht hätten.
Haben sie einfach hornalte
Applaus-Samples
aus den 60ern so eingespielt.
Da hast du richtig gesehen, die Videoqualität
und das Publikum, es waren alles irgendwelche alten
ZD-Alpha-Aufnahmen aus den 60ern.
Also hornalte,
das war super witzig eigentlich, irgendwie musst du damit umgehen.
Aber wenn du zum Beispiel
dir so eine Late-Night-Show
anguckst, die
pausieren, die machen hier dieses
Pause for Laughter, die machen kurze Pause,
wenn sie einen Witz erzählt haben, wo normalerweise
weil es das Publikum lacht und dann hörst du aber kein Publikum,
was lacht.
Ja, das ist bedingt.
Also zum Beispiel bei Last Week Tonight fällt es mir oft auf,
dass das Publikum lacht und er halt weiterredet.
Aber ich fand es genauso ein bisschen irritierend,
das zu sehen, ohne das Publikum, wo du halt eine Pointe hörst.
Du weißt, das war witzig.
Du willst das amüsant finden, aber ohne die,
also zumindest hat mein Hirn da so ein bisschen missfeiert,
ohne die Bestätigung, ja, das war ein Witz,
habe ich dann so kurz, war das überhaupt nicht lustig?
Weil es lacht ja niemand.
Achso, nee, es lacht ja niemand, weil ja niemand da.
Aber trotzdem als Witz gedacht, fand ich interessant, wie mein Hirn da mitgegangen ist.
Ja, ja. Also ich schätze mal, das wird im Umgangston schon vielleicht doch ein bisschen was ändern.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wann wir uns das erste Mal wieder herzlich auf der Straße umarmen
oder wann wir uns mal wieder Hände geben untereinander mit Freunden oder Familie.
Ja, ich winke Leuten immer, glaube ich generell schon. Das passt immer noch. Auch so im Gegenüberstehen.
Bitte was?
Ich wollte mich gerade fragen, hast du den Ellenbogen-Kruß oder hast du den Fußgruß adoptiert?
Weder noch, aber ich finde den Ellenbogen-Kruß amüsant.
Auch wenn ich es weird finde, dass man jetzt die Idee hat, sich mit dem Ellenbogen zu grüßen
und gleichzeitig den Dracula-Husten in den Ellenbogen zu machen.
Ich meine, klar, du hustest dir nicht aus in den Ellenbogen und hast vielleicht auch noch was drüber,
aber trotzdem ist es derselbe Körperteil.
Der Dracula-Husten?
Ich meine, du siehst mich jetzt nicht, weil die Kamera irgendwie eingebrochen ist.
glaube ich zumindest bei mir, dass du so den, wenn du deinen Umhang
so vor dich hältst und dann so in den Ellbogen reinhusten kannst.
Du könntest mal deine Kamera ausmachen, einfach ein bisschen. Ich schätze mal,
dein Uplink leidet gerade ein wenig. Klingt auch ein bisschen hakelig.
Wir brauchen eh nicht die Kamerabilder hier. Man hört uns ja im Nachhinein nie,
bloß wird ja eh nicht veröffentlicht mit Videos.
Genau. Also wir haben in unseren
Show Notes werden wir dann mal auflisten. Wir haben so ein bisschen gesammelt,
was so unterschiedliche Analyse-Seiten angeht. Ich weiß nicht, es wird wahrscheinlich diese Johns Hopkins
ArcGIS-Seite wird sicherlich bekannt
sein, aber wenn ihr noch irgendwelche interessanten Links habt für Daten
oder Visualisierung dieser Daten, ich habe mal unterschiedliche gesehen,
wo einfach schöne Kartendaten auf Bearbeitung sind.
Nicht, dass es unbedingt gute Laune macht, das sich anzugucken,
aber wir haben ein bisschen was in die Show Notes geschmissen.
Wenn ihr noch irgendwas habt, dann schickt uns das ruhig.
Den Link zu dem witzigen Tool von Friend of the Show Flow,
unter anderem die Quarantänehelden.org-Seite,
finde ich eine schicke Idee, dass man da anmelden kann,
wenn man Probleme hat, sich selbst zu versorgen
oder wenn man in einer Risikogruppe ist,
das Haus nicht verlassen möchte oder anderweitig Hilfe braucht
oder halt die andere Seite ist.
Man kann Hilfe stellen,
Da kann man da eben so eine hilfige Suche ausfällig machen anhand einer Postleitzahl und möglicherweise aushelfen.
Das ist eine ganz gute Idee.
Ist das schon außerhalb von Dresden zu benutzen?
Das ist eigentlich von meinen Suchanfragen her ausschließlich außerhalb von Dresden zu nutzen,
weil nicht Dresden irgendwelche Resultate liefert bisher.
Ah, stimmt. Dementsprechend Quarantäne-Helden.
Mittlerweile kann man sich auch anmelden, dass man mit einer Postleitzahl in der E-Mail hinterlegt wird
und eine E-Mail kriegt, wenn etwas existiert an dieser Postezahl.
Nicht schlecht.
Aber coole Idee auf jeden Fall.
Und ein witziger Projektname noch dazu.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Schade, dass wir es brauchen.
Aber cool, das ist so schnell und es sieht auch sehr gut gemacht aus,
muss ich sagen.
Also die Jungs, die sind echt flott da, solche Seiten rauszubauen.
Weißt du, wann die angefangen haben damit?
Ich meine, das war vor einer Woche oder anderthalb schon online,
aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich es da direkt,
ob es da gelauncht ist oder schon ein paar Tage länger
schon online war. Aber wir haben auf jeden Fall gut
abgesehen, was relevant ist.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Dass es viel relevanter auch hierzulande wird.
Genauso habe ich mir verlinkt
die Seite
virus-hackathon.org
oder virus-hackathon, nachdem du es
den English aussprechen möchtest.
Ist ein deutsches Projekt.
Das ist das, was dieses Wochenende läuft, oder?
Wie war das?
Das läuft jetzt gerade, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Das läuft heute und morgen.
Mir fehlen also ein bisschen die genauen Details.
Ich nehme auch nicht teil, aber ich habe
gesehen, dass über 40.000 Leute
sich da angemeldet haben und in dem,
dass es da witzige Probleme gab, dass die 40.000
Leute versucht haben, in den Slack reinzukriegen
und das nicht ging,
weil ein Invite-Link nur für 1.000 Leute
gültig ist und haben immer auf Twitter
gefragt und ich glaube, es war irgendwie
entweder jemand von Slack oder sogar Slack-CEO
oder irgendwas, der meinte, was, 40.000
Leute auf einmal einladen, das fühlt sich nicht so clever an.
Allerdings haben sie es dann doch geschafft, die händisch
einzuladen.
Eieiei.
Scheiße.
Naja, also diese ganzen
Infrastrukturbetreiber fahren gerade alle
ihre, also diese ganzen Kommunikationsbetreiber
fahren gerade alle ihre Infrastruktur ganz schön
hoch.
Gerade weil jetzt sehr viele Leute
remote arbeiten. Aber ich wollte dir eigentlich gerade
erzählen, dass ich gestern bei einer Konferenz war. Das haben wir
dann im Podcast typischerweise abgebrochen.
Erzähl mal, was waren sie überhaupt
für eine Konferenz? Also das war die
Oxidize
Rust-Konferenz für Embedded Rust. Die hätte normalerweise
im Juni stattgefunden, aber da
selbst im Juni stattfindende Konferenzen bereits abgesagt sind,
haben die Organisatoren sich gedacht, gut, okay, dann machen wir was anderes, organisieren
wir mal relativ flott eine Online-Konferenz oder eine Homeference
und die haben das rumgeschrieben, man konnte
sich anmelden, man konnte tatsächlich ein Ticket kaufen, das heißt, ich habe für 10 Euro ein Ticket gekauft
und mit dem Ticket hast du eine Einladung bekommen
und das war dann über Videokonferenz.
Hast einen Link gekriegt, ging ganz gut. War jetzt ein Produkt, was ich selber noch nicht
benutzt hatte. Und gleichzeitig haben sie einen eigenen Matrix
Home-Server aufgezogen. Der ist geowned von Berlin RS.
Das ist halt, also
Oxidice ist auch mitorganisiert von Florian Gelcher.
Und der Crew, also ich weiß nicht, ob er wirklich deep involviert ist, aber es ist alles so dieser Ferris Systems Dunstkreis. Und die haben irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Matrix vielleicht besser gegangen wäre, die haben auf einer Seite, ich suche es mal raus, ob ich es finde, die haben auf einer Seite Oxidize, äh genau, ich schreibe es mal ins Pad, bloß so aus, die Konferenz ist mittlerweile wie gesagt vorbei.
Aber vielleicht kommt es sich jetzt erstmal für dich zum Angucken. Ich habe auf Zeile 31 einen Link hinzugefügt. Und da haben sie einfach ganz viele Matrixräume auf diesem Home-Server aufgemacht. Ein Welcome, ein Announcements, ein Community Announcements, ein Music, ein Moderation. Und dann haben sie für jeden Talk einen Raum aufgemacht, für jeden einzelnen Talk. Die Talks gingen allerdings bloß so 15 bis 20 Minuten.
Okay.
Hab danach nicht mehr sonderlich mitgemacht.
Okay, aber hat das geklappt oder hast du das Gefühl, dass es geklappt hat mit dem Chat-Räumen?
Also die Chat-Räume zu betreten war erstmal schmerzhaft.
Du hast irgendwie hier zu jedem zwei Links einen Riot.im-Link, der dich direkt auf Riot führt.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich das einfach machen sollen.
Ich wollte es aber in meinem Desktop-Riot aufmachen.
Okay.
Und das ging relativ schwierig.
Glücklicherweise hatten sie Links zu allen Räumen noch in diesem Welcome-Channel verlinkt.
Aber der Homeserver, auf dem das war, ist gestern schon ganz schön laggy geworden dabei. Also man merkt, dass Matrix nicht so 100 pro für Realtime optimisiert ist.
Ja, es hat halt schon Probleme. Wenn die Last richtig hart steigt, dann merkst du, dass das richtig unangenehm wird, wenn er versucht, das Zeug irgendwie, wie nennt man das, diese Eventual Consistency, wenn er versucht, das auszugleichen.
Auf jeden Fall.
das alles in die richtige Reihenfolge zu bringen und die Homeserver miteinander zu sinken oder die Clients.
Das bricht dann schon so ein bisschen ein bei Servern, die hart unter Last stehen.
Und ich hoffe sehr, dass das mit Weiterentwicklung von Synapse
beziehungsweise mit Dendrite angenehmer nutzbar wird. Gerade Matrix.org merkt man auch richtig
hart an, dass das gerade alle paar Tage oder alle paar Stunden hart in die Knie geht.
Ja, also bei unserem Videokonferenzsystem, was wir benutzen,
merkt man der Videoqualität teilweise an, welche Uhrzeit ist.
Okay.
Weil die Leute alle ihre Meetings so zur vollen Stunde starten.
Ah, sehr geil.
Und da haben wir schöne Lastspitzen zur vollen Stunde.
Da geht die Videoqualität so ein bisschen zurück.
Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen hochfahren.
Und dann so gegen drei Viertel wird es wieder schön smooth.
Ist ja super witzig, dass man da so ein Schema über eine Stunde hinweg schon sehen kann.
Aber an dieser Stelle wollte ich nochmal erwähnen, es gab neulich einen Change-Log.
mit dem einen
Co-Founder.
changelog.org
Wie hieß das?
Ich hab da kaum weiß es, also
The Change Log
Genau, da gab's
The History of Curl
Sie macht relativ viel Zeugs hier.
Am 9. März war
Matthew von Matrix.
Genau, den meinte ich.
Das wirft mich vor ein ganz anderes Problem hier, ohne tägliche Commute zur Arbeit. Wie zum Teufel höre ich denn jetzt Podcasts?
Tja, gute Frage. Ich hatte erst überlegt, dass ich das wahrscheinlich beim Kochen, Aufwaschen, Sachen zusammenlegen, Wäsche aufhängen oder sowas machen würde. Aber du kannst dich ja nur so und so viel wirklich beschäftigen.
Also was ja momentan noch geht, ist, dass du mit dem Fahrrad durch die Gegend fährst, ein bisschen Sport machst, Joggen gehst. Dabei könntest du Podcasts hören.
Ja, das war vor zwei Tagen ganz angenehm, aber jetzt ist das Wetter auch nicht so ansprechend dafür.
Nee, ich habe mir tatsächlich, weil ich gestern während dieser Konferenz irgendwie was nebenbei mit den Händen machen wollte, was mein Gehirn nicht belastet, dachte ich, ich habe doch mal gehekelt. Ich könnte vielleicht mal wieder ein bisschen weiter häkeln.
Also ich kann wirklich nicht gut häkeln. Ich kann eigentlich gar nicht häkeln. Ich habe irgendwann mal drei Minuten lang einen Knoten gezeigt bekommen und es reicht, um damit irgendwie so kleine Beutel und Taschen zu machen.
Perfekt.
Und ich habe so eine halbfertige Laptop-Tasche,
die passte auch super um mein damaliges
Netbook, was irgendwie
11 Zoll hatte.
Irgendwann habe ich überlegt, dass ich mal eine für
ein MacBook machen könnte.
Aber da musste irgendwie dreimal so viel
Stoff verwenden.
Da dachte ich, fange ich mal wieder an.
Und was habe ich? Ich habe keine Häkelnadel mehr.
Die habe ich irgendwie beim Auszug aus meiner WG
dort gelassen.
Ich habe mir also gestern bei Amazon noch ein Set Häkelnadeln
bestellt.
Nice, aber finde ich eine witzige Idee,
das nebenbei zu machen.
Was machst du denn so, wenn du so alleine zu Hause haugst?
Du hast wenigstens Katzen, ne?
Ja, gutes Argument,
aber das sind jetzt traditionellerweise
nicht so die Tiere mit harten Beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten.
Die kann man schon bespielen,
aber auch nicht den ganzen Tag lang.
Ansonsten, ja,
hier versuchen, irgendwie
mich zu motivieren, an irgendwelchen Side-Projects
zu arbeiten. Habe versucht, ein bisschen
an Mio rumzuhacken und ansonsten
ziemlich hart an
Netflix und Plex-Inhalte konsumieren.
Ich veröde
so ein bisschen, aber
würde ich auch noch weitergeben.
Naja, deswegen bin ich mal gespannt.
Liebe Zuhörer, bitte gebt uns eure
Tipps, was ihr zu Hause in der
Isolation so an Aktivitäten
macht.
Das hat man schon über VR-Brillen gesprochen letztes Mal.
Das wäre eigentlich voll das nice Feature,
sich jetzt gemeinschaftlich zusammenzusetzen
und irgendwas zu machen.
Bei dem Ding habe ich mir neulich gedacht,
das hätte ich jetzt gerne, was du da beim letzten
Jahr erzählt hast. Wie heißt die?
So ein, ich meine letztendlich
jegliche Form von VR-Brille, aber das war eine Oculus,
ohne jetzt Werbung machen zu wollen.
Muss ich nochmal gucken.
Vielleicht hole ich mit noch eine.
Naja.
Wollen wir mal weiter, haben wir jetzt
irgendein Thema gerade links liegen lassen, was ich angesprochen hatte.
Abgesehen davon, dass wir gerade Netflix
angesprochen haben, können wir auch darüber klatschen.
Ja, genau. Also lassen wir ansonsten mal
die weiteren Corona-Themen jetzt weg.
Da wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen was passieren.
Und sobald diese Sendung
raus ist, ist das eh veraltet, was wir hier erzählen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich dann schon irgendwie
die
Zombie-Apokalypse komplett ausgebrochen sein.
Nee, das ist immer
halt Netflix.
Die hatten jetzt angekündigt,
ich glaube, die EU hat die sogar
aufgefordert, das korrekte Wort ist,
aber es hieß, Netflix soll doch
bitte mal, beziehungsweise Netflix und YouTube
sollen, weil die
zusammen für sehr viel Traffic
verantwortlich sind hier,
diesen Kontinenten oder generell weltweit,
sollen die doch bitte mal schauen, ob die irgendwie
Bandbreiten der Qualität zurückschrauben können, um
da Bandbreite zu sparen für
die Leute, die jetzt eh vermehrt, also
weil jetzt jeder zu Hause sitzt und viel mehr
das Internet nutzt, vermutlich,
also
Gut, schwierig zu, ich weiß nicht ganz, ist es korrekt, dass Leute mehr Internet nutzen, wenn sie zu Hause sind? Klar, ich meine, nicht andere Leute arbeiten in den Feldern, wo wir arbeiten und man auch beruflich viel Internet nutzt, aber wenn man mehr Zeit zu Hause hat, bringt das wirklich wahrscheinlich tragbar, die Haushalte.
Naja, es werden wahrscheinlich jetzt momentan auf jeden Fall mehr Leute, die sonstig abends sozial getroffen hätten, trotzdem Netflix gucken und es werden mehr Arbeiten über das Internet allgemein ausgeführt, die vorher nicht online gemacht wurden. Also es machen jetzt gerade fast alle Homeoffice, die es können.
Das stimmt. Ich hoffe nur, dass die Politiker jetzt sehen, was unsere Infrastruktur hierzulande eigentlich hergibt und was die Telekom ihnen versprochen hat über die letzten Jahrzehnte und was davon nicht da ist. Ob man da vielleicht mal ein bisschen dann in Zukunft Motivation findet, das zu ändern.
Ich hatte heute einen Thread offen, der das ziemlich gut erklärt hat, warum das war und ich finde ihn leider gerade nicht wieder. Ich suche den mal, wenn ich den doch wieder finde, packe ich den mal noch in die Show Notes, aber es ging, glaube ich, in der Erklärung hauptsächlich darum, dass einige Anbieter in Italien zum Beispiel kleinere ISPs mit ihrem Peering nicht hinterhergekommen sind.
Und dadurch, dass Netflix zum Beispiel keinen direkten Server in Italien zum Beispiel hat, hat das ein paar ISPs verstopft, wenn Leute sich dann damit quasi Richtung Deutschland zum Beispiel, wo das steht, verbinden wollten.
Das hat jetzt in Deutschland, glaube ich, nicht so richtig eine gute Begründung. Aber sie haben es zum Beispiel nicht geschafft, geolokal in den Ländern noch zusätzliche Kisten hinzustellen und deswegen nehmen sie gerade die Quali ein bisschen runter. Aber im Endeffekt haben sie auch bloß die Kompression erhöht und quasi die Bitrate gesenkt und nicht wirklich die Auflösung runtergenommen.
Das ist vielleicht ganz interessant, dass sie immer noch die Filme in 4K streamen und die Bitrate bloß einschrauben.
Genau. War clever.
Na, es macht schon was aus.
Du hast halt dadurch eventuell
ab und zu mal ein Artefakt, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob ich nicht vielleicht lieber den Film dann nicht
in 4K gucken würde.
Spannende Frage. Ich habe mir gedacht, ich sehe doch auch
gar keinen Unterschied, weil ich gucke
Netflix auch nur am Browser. Dementsprechend
habe ich es eh nie in 4K gesehen,
leider dummerweise.
Ich glaube, ich zahle auch gar nicht für dieses 4K-Konzept
von denen.
Ja.
Naja.
Ich reiche den Thread mal nach, wenn ich ihn finde.
Ich scrolle gerade durch meinen Twitter durch und habe ihn gerade leider nicht offen.
Dumm, dumm, dumm.
Das ist mir auch dummerweise gerade erst eingefallen, als wir es wieder angesprochen haben.
Na gut, okay.
Also Netflix funktioniert aber immerhin noch.
Wo ich mir ja vorstellen kann, dass die auch ihre Kapazitäten momentan ganz schön hochfahren.
Wo Netflix ja eigene Rechenzentren betreibt.
Oder wie war das bei Netflix?
Machen sie das wirklich?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Denke ja.
Ne, ich höre jetzt ja auf mit Suchen, das macht keinen Sinn.
Wenn ich es nochmal finde, trage ich es nach.
Es war irgendwo, vielleicht hatte ich es geliked oder sowas.
Ja, würde ich wahrscheinlich, um an dem Thema zu bleiben,
für die stark rentieren, bei den Anforderungen, die die haben,
nicht auf große Cloud-Infrastruktur zu gehen.
Das wäre ja Milliardenbetrieb, die du zahlen müsstest bei AWS.
Die machen auch, die machen auch,
die haben ihre eigene Linux-Distro und die
haben schon relativ gutes Engineering da drin,
möglichst viel, das ist ja wirklich, das ist ja ein Special-Use-Case,
den sie haben, also die Rechner müssen wirklich nur schnell
viele Daten von der Platte ins
Netz schieben können und darauf haben sie sich schon einigermaßen optimiert.
Gut, also ich...
Ne, ich höre jetzt nicht auf zu suchen.
Ja, ich kann nicht aufhören, ich kann nicht aufhören.
Was ist denn sonst noch so passiert?
Zurück ins Pad.
Wir haben gar keine Programmiersprachenthemen heute, fällt mir auf.
Doch, ich hatte eine.
Ich hatte irgendwo eine.
Ach, da oben, ich sehe es.
Futhark, was ist denn Futhark?
Genau.
Da ist...
Schau dir mal.
Schau dir den mal an.
Das Logo ist ein Igel.
Und die Typ-Annotationen
sehen aus wie Rust.
Und die Syntax sieht angelehnt
aus an Rust.
Nee, das sieht eher aus wie ein Hesker, ehrlich gesagt, oder?
Okay, doch, so mehr Syntax ist ja...
Ich habe Syntax sieht bei mir jetzt gerade, ich sehe Let's, ich sehe
Klammern, die Patzen.
Okay, aber gut, wenn ich hier unten
gerade mehr so schaue...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ist das hier ein großes
An-Web-State? Okay, was sind das generell für eine Sprache?
Erzähl mal.
Don't put me on the spot, ich hatte da kein Häkchen reingemacht
in die Box.
Achso, ich hatte kein Häkchen reingemacht.
Hier oben du hast den High Performance
Purely Functional Data Parallel Array
Programming on the GPU. Okay,
interessant.
Aber ich bin inspiriert von
Rust.
Elementen zumindest.
Fork me
on GitHub. Warum hatte ich die
in meiner Liste? Weil sie
in Hacker News an mir vorbeigescrollt
waren. Ich habe sie mir noch nicht angeschaut.
Das ist auf jeden Fall, die Sprache selber ist in Haskell gebaut.
It's a purely functional data
parallel programming language. It's optimizing
compiler is able to compile
it to typically
very performant GPU code.
Das ist also
dann eher ein Ersatz für so ein
Ach ja genau, zum Ausführen brauchst du sowas wie
OpenCL oder CUDA.
Ist also nichts,
womit du mal eben deinen
Matrix-Client schreiben würdest.
Okay, ich habe echt wenig Ahnung von Dingen, die man auf der GPU laufen lässt. Da bin ich eigentlich voll raus. Ich kenne den Stack nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was man da großartig mit anfangen kann. Also ich, klar, ich weiß, was man auf einer GPU berechnen lassen kann.
mir fehlt einfach, ich habe noch nie einen persönlichen Use Case
gesehen, deswegen
habe ich da echt wenig Ahnung.
Naja, du siehst ja auch dieser Sprache an, dass
vornehmliche Zahlen in und her schiebt.
Ja, typische GPU-Operation.
Naja, wenn du jetzt so einen Instagram-Filter damit bauen möchtest, zum Beispiel.
Aber ich mache mich auch gerade komplett zum Close, weil es
garantiert sinnvollere Anwendungen für
OPCL gibt als
Video- oder Image-Processing.
Schaut es euch an.
Es gibt eine neue Programmiersprache, die
aussieht wie Haskell.
Aber andere Nachrichten. Hast du dich eingelesen zum
Thema NPM-Fuckup
der Woche? Das dürfen wir ja jetzt nicht
mehr so nennen demnächst. Beziehungsweise
mal schauen, wie wir den NPM-Fuckup
jetzt betiteln.
Oder gab es wirklich
einen NPM-Fuckup? Ne, es gab nicht
wirklich einen NPM-Fuckup. Die NPM-Fuckups
heißen jetzt GitHub-Fuckups der Woche.
Und zwar,
wir hatten es schon ein, zwei Mal erwähnt,
dass NPM so eine seltsame Situation hat.
Das ist irgendwie so der Backbone der
JavaScript-Entwicklungsinfrastruktur,
wo alle Pakete
gehostet werden.
Und die gehörte aber dummerweise einer
Venture-Capital-Firma, weil die sich irgendwann,
nachdem es mit den drei Mongo-
DB-Instanzen, die sie hatten, nicht mehr ausgereicht hat,
haben sie sich Geld von irgendwelchen Venture-Kapitalisten
Und haben dementsprechend
einem Venture Capital gehört.
Und deswegen sind da auch irgendwann
relativ viele Leute von weggerannt und gesagt,
damit möchte ich nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Das ist Open Source, was an welchen Firmen gehört.
Und ich saß in der JS-Conf
in dem Vortrag über Entropic,
wo die CJ,
jetzt habe ich schon wieder keine Referenz,
wie heißt die Person?
CJBot.
die hat ihren Namen da auch nicht drin stehen,
CJ Bot auf Twitter,
darüber geredet hat, wie sie jetzt mit Entropic anfängt
und was an NPM alles, also der Firma alles blöd ist.
Und die hat dann noch den Spruch abgelassen,
we can't all be bought by Microsoft,
weil ja kurz zuvor GitHub selber von Microsoft gekauft wurde.
Und jetzt gehört NPM quasi auch zu Microsoft.
War das quasi eine Challenge accepted,
weil die Microsoft-Leute das zugehört haben bei dem Talk oder was?
Ich meine, GitHub genießt jetzt so als Open-Source-Sparte von Microsoft diesen Welpenschutz.
Microsoft steckt da einfach Geld rein, weil die genau wollen, dass GitHub genauso weitermacht, wie sie es jetzt machen.
Aber wenn du mal überlegst, Microsoft gehört jetzt GitHub, mit GitHub gehört ihnen quasi auch Elektron.
oder zumindest Atom.
VS Code haben sie selber gebaut.
Das ist einer der größten Entwickler,
eigentlich die momentan beliebteste JavaScript-IDI.
Sie haben TypeScript entwickelt,
was jetzt die beliebteste Compile-to-Java-Script-Sprache ist.
Eigentlich gehört den JavaScript so ein bisschen jetzt.
Tja, so ein bisschen haben sie den Stack in der Hand.
Haben auch viele Leute auf Twitter schon geschrieben,
von wegen alles, woran ich arbeite, mit dem ich arbeite,
mit der ganze Tech-Stack gehört eigentlich Microsoft.
Jetzt frage ich mich eigentlich nur noch, wann sie mich kaufen,
weil dann ist das ja auch getan.
Naja, du gehörst denen schon quasi.
Ja, ist witzig, weil eigentlich,
du arbeitest mit Microsoft-Produkten auf der vollen Ebene jetzt,
aber letztendlich sind deine meisten,
die Nutzer, die die Software ausführen, die du geschrieben hast,
die meisten doch tatsächlich auf dem Google-Flagship-Produkt unterwegs.
Mit Chrome.
Ja, genau.
An dem Microsoft jetzt übrigens mitentwickelt.
Sie arbeiten direkt an Chrome mit?
Ich dachte, sie haben...
Achso, ja, quasi in dem Sinne, dass sie die Blick-Engine jetzt auch mit nutzen,
um Edge zu bauen oder was.
Also die Absicht von Microsoft mit ihrer Edge-zu-Chrome-Migration
ist eigentlich, dass sie sehr viele Sachen, die sie in Edge-eigen hatten,
jetzt zu Chromium beisteuern.
Und da posten sie auch relativ regelmäßig Sachen,
die jetzt in Edge gehen,
die dementsprechend dann demnächst auch in Chrome gehen.
Die wandern nicht immer sofort upstream.
Also ich glaube, sie sind noch ein bisschen
der Entwicklung hinterher.
Oder sie sind halt so, dass sie die Sachen wahrscheinlich erst
in Edge testen und dann irgendwann komplett in Chrome upstream.
ich weiß nicht genau, wie das Entwicklungsmodell ist,
aber
sie haben schon die Absicht, massiv
an Chromium mitzuentwickeln.
Interessant, okay.
Also damit wird quasi meine
Vermutung, dass
Chromium zu so einer Art
Linux-Körnel des Internets wird,
oder des Webs wird, schon
relativ nahe getreten.
Da haben Sie die Frage von.
Also finde ich auch absolut
verständlich, dass es in die Richtung sich weiterentwickelt.
Nicht, dass ich das unterstützen möchte, aber
Ich finde es interessant und nachvollziehbar und auf jeden Fall zu erwarten, dass es sich so entwickelt.
Da gab es auch einen relativ guten HTTP 203 zu dem Podcast, den ich letzte Woche schon empfohlen hatte,
HTTP 203, also tatsächlich in dem Podcast ein Interview mit einem der ehemaligen Edge, jetzt Edgeium-Entwickler,
packe ich einfach mal mit in die Shownotes.
Was ein bisschen bitter war damals, als das kurz nachdem das bekannt gemacht wurde, dass Edge jetzt umsteigt auf, ach genau, das vom 22. Mai 2019, naja gut.
kurz nachdem rausgekommen ist, dass Edge jetzt auf Chromium umsteigt,
hat dann auch irgendein Microsoft-Mitarbeiter so einen dummen Spruch auf Twitter abgelassen,
naja, wir machen das nur, weil wir das Web so lieben,
eine Monokultur unterstützen und wenn Mozilla das Web genauso lieben würde wie wir,
dann würden sie auch nicht mehr ihren eigenen Browser entwickeln,
sondern auch Chromium mit unterstützen.
Ich glaube, was?
Wo er sich erstmal so ein bisschen Shitstorm eingefangen hatte.
Ja, das ist
ouch. Okay.
Also,
aber ja,
dementsprechend haben wir jetzt MS Internet.
Tja,
alles gehört Microsoft.
Mal schauen, wann sie verkacken. Bisher
läuft GitHub ja angenehm weiter.
Ich unterstütze die Dinge,
die sie bei GitHub macht, zumindest öffentlich.
Aber man weiß natürlich nicht,
was sie erstens hintenrum machen und
andererseits, wie es sich in die Zukunft weiterentwickeln wird.
Das wird sich alles zeigen müssen.
Ich schätze mal, das gehört alles mit
einfach hauptsächlich zu ihrer Image- und PR-Kampagne.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie GitHub
wirklich direkt für Sachen nutzen wollen.
Sie wollen halt hauptsächlich als die Firma
dastehen, die GitHub unterstützt.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ja, möglicherweise.
Kriegt man Entwickler auf deine Plattform,
wenn du so ein Image hast wie Microsoft.
Das ist jetzt ein Platz ja bei denen.
Nein, weil sie die Plattform gekauft haben.
Ja, aber Azure funktioniert genauso gut oder Azure oder wie das ja eigentlich offiziell heißt.
Und, keine Ahnung, selbst LinkedIn nutzen Leute.
Ach stimmt, das gehört ja auch Microsoft.
Aber LinkedIn benutzen die Leute doch nur, wenn sie gerade irgendwie einen neuen Job suchen, oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber du hattest ja noch was in die Notizen reingeschrieben.
GitHub Mobile ist aus der Beta raus.
Ja, die haben ihre App, die jetzt seit ihrer Konferenz vor einem halben Jahr, einem Jahr, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das her ist, die sie da angekündigt hatten und seitdem in der Beta war für iOS und Android.
Ich glaube auch für Android, auf jeden Fall für iOS.
Die haben sie jetzt offiziell released auf beiden Plattformen und die ist, ihr habt die jetzt in der Beta genutzt seitdem und findet die sehr toll und mag die App.
Und ich meine, da steckt vieles an auch interessanten Designentscheidungen mit drin.
Also ich finde hier kein GitHub Mobile, ich finde nur GitHub von GitHub.
Ja, GitHub Mobile habe ich jetzt genannt.
Ich finde es witzig, dass die intern von dem Mobile Team und dem.com Team sprechen.
Das Web Team ist das.com Team.
Ach so. Ah, das ist cool.
Beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich ist das.com Team und das Enterprise Team dann wieder was anderes oder so.
Können wir auch gut vorstellen.
Ja, aber das GitHub Enterprise ist doch die gleiche Software wie GitHub.com, oder?
Ja, vielleicht ist es deswegen.com, weil.com nur.com macht.
Wahrscheinlich.
Können wir über kim.com weiter.
Und was machst du mit GitHub auf deinem Handy?
Ich finde es sehr angenehm, um meine Inbox zu sehen und auf Kommentare zu antworten in Issues und PRs.
Das ist echt super viel angenehmer als die Webseite.
Und man kann sogar ein Review theoretisch machen von der App.
Das habe ich bisher noch nicht getan, weil ich es anstrengender finde als am Rechner.
Aber immerhin ist es so tausendmal angenehmer
als die Mobile-Seite vorher.
Und wie gesagt, ich finde die in ein paar Design-Entscheidungen
recht interessant.
Zum Beispiel kannst du bei,
hast du so einen witzigen Bottom-Draw mit drin,
der nicht so in your face ist.
Wenn du auf der Höhe von einem Issue bist,
dann hast du da so ein Dings,
was du von unten reinziehen kannst,
wo du die Metadaten siehst,
beziehungsweise Kommentare schreiben kannst.
Dann kannst du die erst wieder runterwegschubsen.
Ich finde einfach angenehmes App-Design.
Haben sich echt Mühe gegeben.
Und auch die Leute dahinter sind cool.
Die hat ja angefangen, die App, weil der Ryan Nystrom,
der für iOS die App GitHub geschrieben hat,
mit denen ins Gespräch gekommen ist.
Er hat die App vorher schon geschrieben als eigenes Privatprojekt.
Dann hat sie ein bisschen populärer geworden
und seitdem arbeitet er jetzt dort mit dran.
War GitHub nicht die App, wo du mal schon im Podcast erzählt hattest,
die hatten irgendwie ein iOS-Team und ein Android-Team
und das haben sie dann weggeschmissen und haben ein React-Native-Team?
Oder war das nicht?
Das war Desktop.
Das war GitHub Desktop, oder?
Genau, genau. Das war früher mal.
Ich erinnere mich, wie du das sagst.
Die hatten macOS und die hatten irgendwie
eine Windows-App und die haben sie dann zu einer
Elektron-App gemacht oder sowas.
Genau, das kam dann später, aber die hatten auf jeden Fall
den Reactive Coco-Krams.
Der kam, glaube ich, auch von denen mit raus,
beziehungsweise zumindest von den beiden Leuten,
die da vor allem mit an der macOS-App
mitgearbeitet hatten.
Und lebt das jetzt noch?
Oder ist das dementsprechend mitgestommen?
Gitab Desktop noch gibt, ich habe das nie wirklich benutzt.
Ich fand das immer ein bisschen weird, weil die halt auch versucht haben, so Dinge wie ein Sync-Button
zu etablieren, der irgendwas gemacht hat, je nachdem in welchem State du
gerade warst und das fand ich sehr verwirrend. Du, diese Sync-Buttons, die gibt es
aber auch in VS Code. Da kannst du irgendwie sagen,
synchronisiere dich mal und das
passt irgendwie überhaupt nicht so richtig zu Git. Da habe ich auch jedes Mal
Angst, was passiert denn da jetzt, aber ich glaube,
es macht einfach nur ein Fetch
und ein Push, also ein
Push, wenn es geht,
und ein Fetch,
ansonsten, damit du einfach die
lokal, die Branches siehst, aber
so richtig sicher bin ich mir nicht,
dementsprechend benutze ich ehrlich gesagt Git
immer noch fast ausschließlich
über Kommandozäule.
Okay, ich mache es explizit mit Tastaturkürzeln
in meiner GitGuy-Teral,
aber da weiß ich halt auch, was ich mache
und sehe, was ich tue und nicht irgendwie
Dinge, die etwas zu intransparent sind.
Oh, gut, dass wir hier im
dezentralen Aufnahmebüro sind.
Dezentrales Podcast-Studio.
Bist du noch da?
Oder hast du gerade...
Ich habe mich ein bisschen an meiner Marta verschluckt.
Danach habe ich vergessen, mich zu anmuten.
Verstehe.
Man fühlt sich immer sofort so ein bisschen
schuldig, wenn man mal irgendwo kurz
hustet. Es ist ja nicht so, als ob es nicht noch andere
Erkältungserkrankungen gibt, die man momentan
haben könnte.
Jeder Kranke auf dem Planeten hat aktuell Corona.
Ja, fürchterlich.
Cool, also ich habe mir jetzt mal die GitHub-App installiert
und probiere das einfach mal aus.
Aber du benutzt es auch nicht für Arbeit.
ihr benutzt auch kein GitHub auf Arbeit.
Also einerseits benutzen wir kein GitHub
auf Arbeit, aber andererseits ist die App
auch nicht als Git-Client gedacht,
sondern als GitHub-Client.
Genau.
Finde ich auch ganz sinnvoll. Also es gibt Git-Clients
für iOS und es gibt auch einen fantastischen,
den ich auf dem iPad wieder benutzt habe.
Aber mir würde es auch hauptsächlich
um alles andere drum rum
gehen, um Issues und um
Reviews und
um Pull-Requests
und so weiter und so fort.
dementsprechend ist das schon sinnvoll, also wirklich
Commits machen vom Telefon, das sehe ich auch als Quatsch an,
ehrlich gesagt. Was in der App interessanterweise noch fehlt, ist eine Commit-Übersicht, also du kannst
Repos exploren, du siehst diverse Daten zu Repos, du kannst den Code durchschauen,
aber du siehst nicht die History der Commits, das müssen sie echt mal noch einbauen, da habe ich auch schon
Feedback für Dinge geschickt, aber irgendwie, also
in einem letzten Podcast, wo der Ryan und der Designer der App,
so ein Name mir nicht mehr einfällt, interviewt
wurden von John Sandell,
glaube ich, da haben sie
ein bisschen drüber gesprochen, dass sie daran arbeiten
und das ist aber auch insofern, was ich ganz
witzig fand, dass sie
viele Features von
GitHub.com überdenken, die halt so über die
Jahre gewachsen sind und jetzt schauen, wenn sie
die jetzt neu bauen mit UI
auch in der App, was man da anders
machen könnte und wie das denn anders funktionieren
könnte, das finde ich ganz cool, dass die auch
in die Richtung intern da ein bisschen
zurück-Dogfooden quasi.
Dass sich die
GitHub.com-oberflächlich quasi der App
anpasst. Ja, nicht unbedingt anpasst, aber
einfach neu gedacht wird und nicht
einfach nur auf irgendwelchen Legacy-Fu
aufgebaut wird, den sie halt früher mal so gemacht haben,
weil es so einfacher oder schneller war. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also ich habe jetzt meine
Notification-Ansicht auf GitHub definitiv schon auf
dieses neue
umgestellt und das macht es
wesentlich angenehmer. Ich finde auch, ganz ehrlich,
das haben wir jetzt vor kurzem erst neu gemacht,
ist, dass wenn du auf Notification-Ansicht
auf PRs oder Issues drauf gehst,
dass du da oben diese Leiste hast, mit dem
die blau-Ansicht ist, viel besser
als das, was ich vorher hatte. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Also, wenn ihr das Beta-Feature noch nicht habt,
probiert's mal aus. Ich hab ja noch diesen Button
Revert to Classic, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich will gar nicht
zurück.
Die neue Notification ist
tausendmal besser als die alten.
Auf jeden Fall.
Geil, geil, geil.
Ja, was haben wir noch im Patch stehen?
Irgendwas, was noch los war? Ich hab jetzt neulich mal
und hab mal GitHub Actions auf zwei meiner Repos geschmissen
und hab damit quasi Travis arbeitslos gemacht.
Also da gibt's irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wie das in der,
ich hab's ehrlich gesagt noch nicht wirklich viel gemacht.
Es gibt ein Projekt, das heißt Actions.rs.
Das sind dann alle, das sind einfach so Standardkonfigurationen für Rust.
Und das Schöne ist, wenn du auf GitHub so Actions anlegst,
hast du ja auch so einen Editor, wo du irgendwie neue Actions
einfach in deine Konfiguration reinziehen kannst, dann mache ich noch das und dann mache ich noch das.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice. Also ich habe irgendwie bei einem,
du kriegst halt so ein Standard-Dings, das kannst du dir reinziehen, dann hast du irgendwie Check und Test
und Format und das war's. Was habe ich da noch?
Format habe ich erstmal bei einem Projekt wieder rausgeschmissen, weil der Code noch nicht formatisiert ist
oder formatiert ist. Das ist nochmal ein bisschen
das
Handlungsbedarf.
Nach dem Push automatisch das Format
drüber laufen lässt und dann
die Change zurückcommittet oder meinst du, dass er dann
warnt, wenn es nicht geformatet ist?
Du kriegst dann, der läuft diese einzelnen,
warte mal, wo hab ich's?
Wenn du mal auf
Capodi
iCalendar RS gehst, da hab ich das glaube ich
schon drin, genau.
Ich schieb's mal
ins Riot.
Da wollte ich es nicht reinschreiben.
Da siehst du, dass auf dem letzten Commit,
Latest Commit, oben hast du einen grünen Haken und wenn du da drauf gehst, siehst du halt die einzelnen
Actions, die der Reihe nach ausgeführt wurden. Und das sind einfach bloß so
Konfigurationen. Der macht jetzt hier einen Check. Das erste ist so
ein Setup. Da hoffe ich, dass er nicht jedes Mal die gesamte Environment komplett neu aufsetzt, aber
da zieht er sich irgendwie Rust und diese
Actions Toolchain, das sind ja wahrscheinlich ineinander
geschachtelte Docker-Container oder sowas ähnliches, das weiß ich nicht,
macht dann Checkout und dann der Reihe nach führt er aus, dass er einen Check auf Stable,
einen Check auf Beta und einen Check auf
1.40 macht, also weil das meine Minimum-Rust-Compiler-Version
Requirement ist, dann lässt er meine Tests laufen,
dann formatiert er es einmal, aber er macht quasi nur so ein Format-Check,
dass du keinen unformatierten Code kommittest
und dann
macht er noch ein Clippy oben drüber.
Okay.
Und damit würdest du abgelehnt werden, quasi.
Mir fällt gerade auf, dass man
die Tests wahrscheinlich nach dem Formatting machen könnte
oder nach Clippy, weil ich
mich unwahrscheinlich ärgere, zum Beispiel auf Arbeit, das hatte ich glaube ich schon mal,
wenn du deine CI lostrittst und einen Pull-Request aufmachst und dann läuft
diese gesamte Test-Suite durch und es dauert 10 Minuten,
20 Minuten und zum Schluss sagt er dir übrigens, du hast deinen Code nicht richtig formatiert.
War alles grün, aber musst nochmal von vorne anfangen.
Dann denke ich mir, ja.
Ja, da kann man damit optimieren, dass in der richtigen Reihenfolge
die optimalen Reihenfolge läuft. Genau, das haben wir jetzt auf Arbeit mittlerweile geändert,
dass diese ganzen billigen Checks als erstes gemacht werden,
damit du möglichst schnell ein Feedback kriegst, wenn du was vergessen hast.
Ja, bestimmt voll. Und was ich hier auf
Arbeit habe, was ich gerne noch auf meine Projekte schmeißen würde, was allerdings, ich habe noch keine schöne Art und Weise gefunden, das zu machen, ist Conventional Change Log oder Conventional Commit Checks zu machen. Benutzt ihr Conventional Commits?
Nö.
Weißt du, was das ist?
Wir hatten das Thema schon mal angesprochen. Ich habe mir auch einen Tab dazu noch offen irgendwo, aber ich habe mich ja nicht, also ich kenne das Konzept, glaube ich, schon, dass du halt irgendwie die Commits annotierst mit Nachrichten, also mit Präfixes oder irgendwie halt irgendeinem Schema, dass du halt klar machst, was das für ein Commit ist oder so.
Genau. Das ist was, was wir jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit auf Arbeit machen in unseren Repos und dementsprechend haben wir auch in der CI Checks, die verifizieren, dass du deine Commit-Nachrichten richtig machst. Das klingt erstmal bescheuert, weil Commit-Nachrichten sind ja schließlich für Menschen, aber dementsprechend sinnvoll ist das Projekt auch eigentlich, wenn du darüber nachdenkst.
Und zwar gibt es da die Information auf conventionalcommits.org und im Endeffekt ist es nichts anderes, als dass du deine Commits weiter so schreibst, wie du sie geschrieben hättest, allerdings schreibst du einen Tag davor, je nachdem, was deine Änderung nun macht.
Ist das ein Feature? Wenn ja, kannst du noch ein Scope angeben. Ist das ein Fix? Dann kannst du noch reinschreiben, ist es ein Breaking Change? Das wäre dann nächste Zeile. Also, du würdest dann schreiben, Feature so und so, habe API so und so geändert und dann kannst du unten drunter in Markdown so eine Zeile in Fet Breaking Change schreiben.
Dann gibt es noch so Sachen, die untergehen, wie Chore oder Refactor oder Test und das Geile ist, dass du halt dann aufgrund von deiner Commit History nicht nur einen Change Log daraus generieren kannst, was ich gerne machen würde, sondern du kannst theoretisch damit auch, wenn du einen Release machst, die nächste Release Version bestimmen.
Kannst nämlich sagen, wenn ich ein, zwei Features, wenn ich nur Fixes hinzufüge, dann ist es ein Minor, wenn ich Features hinzufüge, dann ist es ein Patch-Release, wenn ich Features hinzufüge, ist es ein Minor-Release und wenn ich einen Breaking-Change habe, ist es ein Major-Release.
das eigentlich ziemlich...
Ja, aber wenn eigentlich, also
idealerweise in einer perfekten Welt, wo man auch
das Tooling dafür hätte, will man doch eigentlich eher
die Version Bumps anhand
von den API Boundaries
sehen, oder? Ist natürlich schwieriger als
für das... Das ist je nachdem, in welcher
Sprache du arbeitest, ist
das möglich oder nicht
möglich. Ja, also es kann sein, dass es nicht
drin ist, aber das wäre für eine perfekte
Welt, aber hier ist es ja dann, dass der Mensch dann entscheidet
und drüber schaut oder die Software...
Genau, also es ist, genau, insofern ist es immer
mal besser, als wenn du es
komplett manuell machst.
Oder so.
So kannst du vielleicht, machst du ein Release
nach 10, 15
Commits oder nach
drei Monaten,
wenn du es nur selten machst und dann
überlegst, aha, was für eine Version gebe ich in dem jetzt.
Und so
weißt du es eigentlich relativ gut.
Das
wollte ich auf dieses Projekt
auch noch draufschmeißen. Da gibt es irgendwie schon
Tooling.
Das gibt es für JavaScript-Projekte. Dummerweise ist das dann irgendwie von meiner Sprache abhängig. Mir hat nämlich jemand einen Pull-Request gestellt und ein neues Feature in diese Kalender-Bibliothek eingebaut und der hat halt da fünf Commits gemacht und hat dann hinterher noch manuell den Change-Log aktualisiert und ich hatte aber schon so ein Rust-Tool für Conventional Commits genommen, um manuell den Change-Log zu aktualisieren und der hat dann halt mir einen Pull-Request mit fünf Commits oder acht Commits gemacht,
wo überall dieses Präfix nicht davor stand.
Und dann habe ich quasi seinen Branch nochmal rebased
und bei jeder Commit-Message dann irgendwie dieses Tag davor geschrieben.
Okay.
Und das wäre cool gewesen, wenn das quasi CI beim PR schon validieren könnte.
Dann haut man zwar den Leuten so ein bisschen vor den Kopf,
wenn du sagst, naja, das ist ja schön, dass du mir hier einen Commit machst,
der baut auch und der testet auch, aber du musst
da ja noch deine Commit-Nachrichten anpassen.
Aber das machen halt einige Projekte schon.
Und das geht für JavaScript-Projekte gut. Du kannst einfach
Conventional Commit
Linter oder Commit Linter heißt es glaube ich,
in deinen Package-JSON hinzuschmeißen.
Das muss dann aber irgendwie mit deinem Projekt installiert sein.
Was ich noch nicht gefunden habe, dass das geht,
ist, dass du das einfach in deine GitHub-Action hinzufügst
und quasi dein Projekt selber dadurch nicht anpassen musst.
Ich könnte meinem Rust-Projekt jetzt noch eine Package-JSON hinzufügen
und das mit installieren.
Also, das wäre nicht so geil.
Aber das wäre halt, ja genau, das wäre halt auch nicht so geil.
Schön wäre es, wenn die GitHub-Action oder der Travis-Job
oder was auch immer das einfach so machen könnte.
Wie mag man das aber?
Achso, sorry, erzähl mal weiter.
Aber da gibt es irgendwie noch nicht so richtig was.
Also, du kannst es, wie gesagt, bei NPM-Paketen,
kannst du diesen Commit-Linter zu deinen Dev-Dependencies hinzufügen.
Kannst aber, glaube ich, nicht sagen, linte einfach dieses Projekt,
ohne dass du dem Projekt selber, wie war denn das?
Achso, du hast, das Problem ist bei dem Commit-Lint,
dass der, du hast keine Config-Datei,
sondern du hast so eine Config-JavaScript-Datei,
wo du deine Konfiguration reinschreibst und die erwartet,
in deinem Projekt irgendwie so ein,
dieser Commit-Linter
in deinem Node-Modules-Pfad
irgendwo liegt.
So, das geht natürlich dementsprechend nicht.
Aber vielleicht muss ich einfach noch mal ein bisschen graben,
vielleicht findet sich da eine andere Möglichkeit,
dass das
geht. Also es scheint aber in der
Rust-Community noch niemand so richtig out of the
box zu machen.
Okay.
Aber wie funktioniert
denn sowas generell, also würdest du
was im Open-Source-Umfeld auch nutzen,
wenn jemand dir ein PR aufmacht,
da achtet doch wahrscheinlich niemand drauf,
ob es da irgendwie schon eine Guideline für gibt.
Und dann nochmal die Commitment,
die sich im Nachhinein ändern,
ist doch viel zu viel Aufwand.
Naja, du hast doch häufig bei GitHub-Projekten
so eine Contribution-MD
oder so eine Contributing-MD.
Ja, die liest doch auch niemand.
Die liest doch auch niemand.
Dann hast du im GitHub-Umfeld
so Issue- und Pull-Request-Templates.
die werden einigermaßen gelesen, hoffentlich.
Dann hast du häufig, also Code of Conduct beschäftigt sich mit solchen Formalien
eigentlich nicht. Aber dementsprechend wäre es eigentlich ganz
nice, wenn du quasi, wenn die Leute den Pull-Request
aufmachen, wenn sie dann von einem Roboter gesagt bekommen, dass sie bitte was ändern sollen, anstatt dass ich die
da freundlich drum bitten muss.
Und wenn das mehrere schon machen, also selbst ohne,
Wenn ich irgendwie einen Pull-Request mache, das ist jetzt nicht selbstverständlich, aber wenn ich einen Pull-Request an irgendeinem Projekt mache, schaue ich erstmal, was sind denn so die Konventionen, wie die hier ihre Commit-Messages schreiben. Ich habe selber bei meinen Projekten, wo ich nicht damit rechne, dass jemand mitarbeitet, auch keine strengen Konventionen, schreibe es mal so, mal so. Da gibt es aber, bei mir auf Arbeit gibt es ein paar Leute, die da relativ strikt sind, wie das auszusehen hat.
Also die einzige Vorgabe, die wir auf Arbeit haben, ist, dass in den Commit der Ticket Identifier mit reingehört.
Genau, da gibt es aber auch unterschiedliche Konventionen.
Manche schreiben ihre Tickets irgendwie in die Commit-Zeile mit rein, in die erste Zeile, was absoluter Quatsch ist.
Manche schreiben es in den Branch-Namen mit rein, was auch nicht unbedingt muss.
Es reicht eigentlich, wenn du es irgendwo im Subtext oder im Beschreibungstext von deinem Commit erwähnst.
Klar.
Also bei Apple war es so, dass immer diese typische Radar-Syntax mit reingehackt wurde irgendwo am Ende des Commits.
Genau.
Bei uns ist es tatsächlich so, dass das, was du gerade meintest, im Branch-Namen steht, aber auch nur, weil die meisten von uns den Branch direkt aus dem Jira heraus erstellen lassen.
Ah, verstehe.
Aber das ist einfach nur ein Komfortabilitätsding.
Und kann aus Jira heraus Branches erzeugen?
Ja, da direkt ein, hier ist ein Ticket und dann machst du direkt ein Create Branch from this, so ein Button an der Seite und dann erstelle ich den Branch und den checke ich dann aus und dann lege ich es direkt da drauf.
Dann hat er den Vorteil, dass es direkt verlinkt ist. Das macht er, glaube ich, von meinem Namen her abhängig, das spricht, du kannst ihn auch selber anlegen, aber du musst es dann den, wahrscheinlich, wenn du die Issue-Nummer mit angibst, dann ist das da auch mit drin.
Und dann kann Jira den Branch und das Ticket zusammen assoziieren, ja?
Genau, dann hast du zumindest den Link am Ticket mit drin, was für das Review später ganz nett ist.
Aber das hast du auch, wenn du das Ticket einfach nur irgendwo in deinem Commit erwähnst.
Ja, das dachte ich mir fast, aber okay.
Das reicht. Und dazu muss es auch nicht in der ersten Zeile stehen. Also ich wusste das gar nicht, dass man aus Jira heraus Branches erzeugen kann, aber das macht natürlich irgendwie Sinn.
Ich habe da bei mir aus Git-Extras dieses Feature.
Da sagt ich einfach Git-Feature und dann noch ein paar Wörter
und dann erzeugt er mir einen Branch, der heißt Feature-Slash
und dann was auch immer ich hinten dran geschrieben habe als Name.
Ich habe da auch ein Bitbucket-Feature für rein,
aber das ist ja bei Atlassian eher alles so ein riesen zusammengehöriger Stack,
wo man nicht weiß, was du eigentlich nutzt.
Solange es blau ist, gehört es irgendwie dazu.
Solange es blau ist und so aussieht wie GitHub von vor drei Jahren.
Naja, nee, sieht viel schlimmer aus.
Es ist aber besser geworden, muss ich sagen.
Ich bin absolut kein Fan, immer noch nicht.
Also ich fährt langsam ein bisschen gerne mit Jira, aber ich bin kein Fan.
Das ist einfach, wenn es schön ist, du brauchst für manche Sachen komplexe Software,
aber gefühlt nehmen die meisten Firmen einfach nur das, weil es halt die anderen nutzen.
Und natürlich brauchen wir sowas Komplexes, aber niemand braucht sowas Komplexes.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Bei mir ist es, wie gesagt, andersrum.
Bitbucket ist okay, das kann jetzt nicht sonderlich viel,
aber ich finde es einigermaßen übersichtlich.
Aber mit Jira,
das liegt aber glaube ich da bei uns
daran, dass wir einfach so viele unterschiedliche
Boards und Präfixe haben, dass das einfach
und jedes Board hat eine andere
Semantik und fühlt sich anders an.
Dann musst du, wenn ein Ticket
anlegst, musst du noch 35 extra Felder
ausfüllen, die überhaupt nichts mit deiner Arbeit zu tun
haben und das schreckt mich so ab.
Das ist dann Jira.
Genau.
Ich habe auch noch keinen, gibt es,
Habt ihr irgendwie ein Skript, mit dem man
Jira-Tickets automatisch erstellen kann?
Ich habe mal versucht,
die Jira-CLI
irgendwas zum Basteln, aber
so richtig geklappt hat das
auch nicht.
Gut. Also zumindest
eine Zusammenfassung dieses Themas ist
GitHub-Actions
würde ich gerne, muss ich mal mehr mitmachen.
Im Rust-Ummfeld
gibt es halt Actions-RS, da ist einiges
schon drin, aber was mir zum Beispiel noch fehlt, sind
Commit-Lints
ohne dass ich so ein gesamtes JavaScript-Projekt mit Package-JSON mir mit reinziehen muss. Das wäre noch gut. Da kann man wahrscheinlich relativ einfach aus diesem Tool einen Docker-Container bauen und den irgendwo hin publishen und dann dem GitHub-Actions sagen, da guck mal, schmeiß mal diesen Container noch oben drüber und füllen wir da drin dieses Programm aus, weil es gibt schon einen Commit-Linter für der in Rust, der heißt ConfCo. Den kann ich mal unter die Pix schreiben.
Es gibt auch eine ganze Reihe von Custom Third-Party-Actions,
obwohl ich da halt echt, also ich verstehe noch nicht ganz,
wie sie das denken vom Ecosystem her,
weil ich, also ich kann ja beliebige Third-Party-Actions,
die einfach nur jetzt enthinkt, eine YAML-Datei sind,
wo beschrieben ist, was die macht und was die braucht,
und Prequisites, die kann ich mir mit reinziehen in meine Actions,
aber zum Beispiel gibt es sowas wie eine SSH-Action,
wo du halt letztendlich auf der anderen Seite nur noch sagst,
hier, ich möchte bitte, hier sind die Login-Daten,
die sind in meinen Reposequets drin,
ich möchte da einen Command ausführen.
habe ich mal kurzzeitig getestet, weil ich dachte, es wäre witzig, das als Action in das Repo für meine Homepage mit reinzulegen
und bei einem Push, beziehungsweise ein Push-Event ist ja auch ein Merge von einem PR,
wird das automatisch quasi auf meinen, geht ja auf meinen Server und führt da einfach einen Git-Pull aus,
weil da das Repo verlinkt ist und hat somit das geupdated live.
Das fand ich ganz witzig von der Idee her, so als hier billig Deployment-Strategie für eine statische HTML-Seite,
aber gleichzeitig hast du halt eine Action, die SSH-Credentials bekommt.
Und da das direkt eine verlinkte Third-Party-Action ist,
kann die halt auch jederzeit hier gesetzt werden mit,
mach mal was anderes und schick mal die Credentials,
die du bekommst, einfach hier zusätzlich noch am Main-Server.
Und das kriege ich nicht mal wirklich mit.
Aber Actions sind doch auch bloß GitHub-Repositories.
Ja, also ich könnte sehen, dass es passiert,
aber ich würde doch nie wieder die Third-Party-Action auditen.
Vor allem, wenn ich die halt so verlinke in meinem Repo,
dass die halt gepinnt ist auf eine
Version, die sich selber updatet.
Nee, aber du kannst sie forken und
deine eigene... Das ist doch
die Option, die mir dann eingefallen ist, als der Workaround,
aber müsste ich jetzt tatsächlich, ist das der
Workflow, den GitHub mir hier
anbieten möchte,
dass ich hier third-party Actions nutzen kann,
aber bestenfalls forke ich die alle
zu mir und schaue dann
mal wieder regelmäßig rein, ob die Upstream-Changes
haben und nutze das so?
Ist das die Art und Weise,
wie das genutzt werden soll?
Nee, es ist nicht, aber bei Actions, wo du vielleicht ein bisschen kritisch bist, gerade denen, wo du Credentials reingibst, aber ist es nicht auch so, dass du gewisse Keys, das ist nicht dein GitHub-Access-Key, der wird irgendwie von was auch immer diese Actions dann ausführt, einfach so als Environment-Wearable gesetzt?
Ja, aber die Action kann ja machen, was sie möchte, die Action kann ja trotzdem hier diese Credentials nutzen. Ich meine, du kannst ja nicht verifizieren, wofür die genutzt werden, ob die das zum Login bei der Seite nutzt oder ob die das zufällig noch an einen anderen Service mitschickt, ist ja alles möglich.
Stimmt, dementsprechend
Augen auf bei der Action-Wahl.
Guter Folgentitel.
Du schreibst es schon.
Ja, nee.
Prinzipiell finde ich die GitHub-Action bisher sehr gelungen
und machen mir sehr viel Spaß damit, Dinge zu machen
und auch nur einzelne CI-Sachen.
Ich fand es auch ganz witzig. Ich hatte so eine Library geschrieben,
die, ich hoffe, das habe ich noch nicht erzählt gehabt,
die einfach nur ein API-Wrapper ist,
für die Mensa-Daten vom Studentenwerk Dresden.
Du hattest so eine SwiftUI-App für Mensa-Zwecks gemacht, oder?
Genau, eine SwiftUI-Spielerei.
Und weil ich gemerkt habe, dass das Studentenwerk diese API selber nur anbietet,
einfach nur weil sie es, ich weiß gar nicht, aus welchem Grund heraus es eigentlich kam,
ich glaube, das ging auch auf einer anderen Anfrage hervor,
aber die sind das nicht interessiert daran, das wirklich zu maintainen,
beziehungsweise die eine Person, die das macht,
Und ich hatte gemerkt, dass meine App schon dreimal weggestorben ist, weil die API nicht mehr existierte.
Das eine Mal war ein bisschen der Humor, dass die sich Ransomware eingefangen hatten
und generell alles an ihrem System gestorben ist.
Nein.
Wie auch immer, die haben das Ding dann nicht restartet und ich habe dann irgendwann drei Tage später mal eine Mail geschrieben von wegen,
hey, wie schaut es denn aus? Läuft das wieder? Oh ja, ich habe es gerade wieder gestartet.
Eine Stunde später lief es dann wieder.
Und seitdem habe ich mir eine Action, die ja interessanterweise nicht nur auf Push- oder generellen Repo-Events laufen kann,
Genau, habe ich jetzt jeden
Wochentag um 10 Uhr früh
läuft genau ein Teil meiner
Testsuit, der live die
API checkt von denen und mir einfach, der
fehlt nur, wenn die keine Daten liefert.
Und somit kriege ich dann zumindest
eine E-Mail, das kann ich natürlich auch automatisieren, dass
direkt ein Ding gemailt wird, aber das möchte ich nicht machen.
Dementsprechend kannst du
GitHub Actions jetzt komplett als
CI verwenden. Du kannst
komplett als CI verwenden, du kannst auch diverse
andere Dinge machen, du kannst ja aus den
Was spricht denn dagegen, dass ich hier jede Stunde versuche, da ich ja unendlich CPU-Ressourcen nie habe auf öffentlichen Repos, dass ich hier minütlich versuche, Bitcoins zu minen mit GitHub-Actions. Das ist doch alles.
Ja, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass einige von diesen, ich muss nochmal den Bogen zurückschlagen zu Coronavirus, es gibt ein paar Repos, wo einfach bloß Zahlen und Fakten drin liegen zur Verbreitung. Ich weiß nicht, wie aktuell die momentan noch sind, aber du kannst theoretisch, kannst du Actions bauen, die dir deine Skripte, die dir Daten scrapen und dann auf GitHub packen?
Ja. Wir haben in der offenen Dresden-Organisation ja auch diesen Rats-Info-Scraper, der immer noch läuft, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das noch aktuell genutzt wird oder irgendwas, der einfach nur die Dachen von offiziellen Dresden.de-Seiten runterscrapt und archiviert in dem Repo selber. Und sowas könnte man halt prima über die Actions mitlaufen lassen, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, es gab auch mal irgendwie eine GitHub-Org mit allen Bundesgesetzen drin oder so.
Die gibt immer noch, das Bundesgit.
Genau, aber die ist einigermaßen tot, oder?
ich habe schon lange nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Bundestag, GitHub.com
slash Bundestag slash Gesetze zum Beispiel,
aber da ist die letzte Commit sieben Jahre her, das stimmt.
Genau.
Was ich ja gehofft hatte, ist, dass sie da nicht nur
die Dinge archivieren,
sondern dass sie das genauso, die
Commits halt dementsprechend,
die Authors und die Timestamps passend
setzen, dass man halt sieht, wo das
herkommt und vor allem, wann das kam.
Und was auch in der Vergangenheit zum
Beginn der Bundesregierung, das wäre toll gewesen.
Das haben sie leider nicht gemacht, aber sie hatten es regelmäßig gescrapt, sodass du Diffs in den Gesetzestexten sehen kannst.
Das ist auch echt wertvoll.
Ja, allerdings ist es leider tot, denn ich gucke gerade auf Bundestagsgesetze-Issues und da gibt es ein Issue, letzter Commit vor drei Jahren und dieses Issue selber ist von 2015 und es ist noch offen.
Also es ist wirklich, es ist glaube ich dort.
Es ist zumindest seit einiger Zeit nichts mehr dran passiert.
Es war aber eine schöne Idee.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich hätte auch vor einer Zeit lang mal ein Projekt begonnen,
aber nicht sehr weit gekommen.
Ich glaube, da habe ich mit Gilbert mal drüber gequatscht damals.
Hallo Gilbert, falls du uns hörst.
Und zwar gibt es das im englischsprachigen Raum,
aber es gab es nicht für den deutschsprachigen.
Und das wollten, da hatten wir im ASCII mal drüber geplaudert,
sowas aufzusetzen, und zwar so News-Diff,
dass man halt News-Artikel, wie zum Beispiel von der Tagesschau
oder sonst wie, halt archiviert,
und dann einfach nur die Diffs dazu,
wenn die Artikel im Nachhinein bearbeitet werden,
was für Namen geändert werden,
beziehungsweise vor allem, was für Details daraus editiert werden,
dass es sehen kann, weil es ja teilweise doch nicht ganz unkritisch ist,
was da an Geschichtsrevisionismus betrieben wird, manchmal.
Naja, ist das wirklich Geschichtsrevisionismus?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das war jetzt überspitzt, aber...
Die haben zum Beispiel eine Highlight-Seite auch, die machen das, glaube ich, für die New York Times und diverse andere bekannte Sachen. Und auf der Highlight-Seite, die sie gefunden haben, sind so Sachen wie, da stand ein Obituary von Yvonne Brill, die war ein Rocket Scientist, die mit 88 gestorben ist, 2013. Da stand drin der Text, der Lead-Text oben von She Made a Mean Beef Strogonoff zu She Was a Brilliant Rocket Scientist, haben sie geändert.
Wow, also cool, danke, dass die vorher darauf gefokussiert waren,
was sie für ein gutes Beef Stalkanoff machen kann.
Naja, das war...
Oder Sachen wie hier von Mubarak wurde zu Military Care gerusht,
da war die Story, die seine Condition wurde geändert,
von Clinically Dead zu Critical Condition and Still Alive.
Also Dinge, die wirklich schon inhaltlich relevant sind.
Naja, welches von denen war dann wann richtig?
Wenn sie eine Falschmeldung bekommen haben,
dass er tot ist, dann dürfen sie das auch sehr gerne
ändern, dass er halt nicht tot ist.
Ich will ja auch, dass sie es ändern, dass es korrekt ist, aber gleichzeitig
siehst du ja teilweise, dass das Inhalte gelöscht werden,
beziehungsweise ziemlich geändert werden.
Du willst ja trotzdem wissen, was
anfangs da drin stand und wie es geändert wurde.
Das stimmt allerdings.
Es gab ja mal Vicky News, ich weiß nicht,
lebt das noch?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das noch lebt.
Aber es wäre schon cool, wenn du irgendwie
bei jedem Nachrichtenartikel so die
die Editing History
zu einem
So.
Aber ja, das war eine witzige Projektidee damals, die nie wirklich gelebt hat, vor allem, weil ich an meinem Unwissen halt damals gescheitert bin, wie man sowas aufbaut. Ich wollte irgendwie so Dinge wie die von der Tagesschau, einfach so ein Readability-Dings drüber jagen, dass ich halt wirklich hier im Text source den Text bekomme. Und daran bin ich technisch damals gescheitert, aber können wir halt dran gehen.
Aber mit dem Scraper bauen, kennst du dich ja mittlerweile relativ gut aus.
Ja, da habe ich auch keine Lust mehr auf
wirkliche Projekte damit.
Vor allem, weil du ja heutzutage wahrscheinlich sogar
sobald sowas populärer wird, hier instant
verklagt wirst von der Bild oder so,
weil Leistungsschutzrecht und du hast
mehr als drei Wörter gespeichert von denen
oder so, keine Ahnung.
Das Limit ist ja, glaube ich, drei Wörter, was
die jetzt anlegen wollten.
Stimmt, wir haben ja ein Leistungsschutzrecht mittlerweile.
Zitierbar ist kostenlos.
Drei Worte.
Klingel los.
Gut.
haben wir noch schöne Neuigkeiten?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt
nichts mehr wirklich auf der Liste stehen.
Hattest du nicht erwähnt, dass du mit deinen Lieblingsarbeitgeber
jetzt Rust Jobs suchen?
Ja, das stimmt, das steht noch da, genau, weil du kannst dich
aktuell bei der
Fruchtfirma in Cupertino bewerben
als Rust-Entwickler, die machen
da wohl Low-Level-Webkrams
und haben alten
C-Code, den sie langsam wohl umbauen, aber interessant
finde ich sehr cool, dass es auf der Barth weiterläuft,
aber ist ja auch eine gigantische Firma, wo alles mögliche gemacht wird.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Hm, vielleicht frage ich da mal an.
Mach das. Wollen wir uns unseren GitHub-Pix übergeben?
Äh, du meinst unsere Microsoft-Pix?
Ja, genau, unsere Microsoft-Pix der Woche.
Oh Gott.
Ja, schieß los.
Ja, ich habe Windows 10 auf der Liste stehen.
What?
Ah nee, shit, warte mal, das war gerade ein schlechter Scherz,
aber das erste ist ja tatsächlich angelehnt an ein Microsoft-Projekt.
Ach du Scheiße.
Das Erste, was ich draufgeschrieben hatte, war das fantastische Projekt WebXCL geschrieben, also wie Excel, weil es halt genau das ist.
Das ist ein REST Backend Build with Plain Visual Basic Microsoft Excel Macros.
Du baust halt eine Web-Anwendung mit Makros in Visual Basic, also in Excel und das ist halt so großartig.
Allein die Feature Rapid Prototyping oben anzugeben ist, du schreibst die Daten einfach in eine Tabelle und dann läuft das so.
dann hast du quasi hier eine Datenbank, die
eine JSON-API, eine JSON-Werste-API drauf hat.
Aber ich habe das geilste Feature
war,
na, wo steht's?
Die Readme-Scoring ist nicht so nicht lang, aber irgendwo
stand's doch da.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich Visual Basics sehe,
ehrlich gesagt. Hier steht in der
Readme drin, dass das sehr scalable ist, weil
WebXL supports scaling
from a mere 10% to 400%
for extreme detailed data
inside. This makes it a perfect fit for
small startups to global corporations.
By default WebExcel
Projects are scale 100%,
but you can adjust the setting in the lower right corner
of Microsoft Excel to fit your needs.
Also er spricht über das Zoom-Feature.
Ach so.
Ach du Scheiße.
Also von Detailed Data Insights.
Du kannst weiter reinzoomen und siehst Detailed Data Insights.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ich finde das total großartig.
Tolles Projekt.
Ernst meint der das?
Unten ist verlinkt. Is it any good?
und darunter steht Yes.
Das verlinkt zu einem Klassiker,
einem Hacker-News-Kommentar. Genau.
Ich habe noch, was ich ganz witzig fand dazu,
war das das klassische Projekt des
Webservers, der in PostScript geschrieben ist.
Das ist ein
8 Jahre altes Projekt auf GitHub.
Das ist eine 200 Zeilen PostScript-Datei.
Ja.
HTTP
ist ein relativ einfaches Protokoll,
wenn du kein HTTPS oder
HTTP 2 unterstützt.
Ja, aber auf Postscript,
ich liebe es ja, so Technik zu missbrauchen,
für was ein ganz anderer
Anwendungsfall ist. Ach du Scheiße,
wie sieht das aus?
Es ist einfach nur geil. Ich erinnere mich an diesen
HTTP-Server, der auf einer Kartoffel lief,
der irgendwie einen halben Schritt pro Sekunde
beantworten konnte. Oh nein!
Also der war irgendwie
Kartoffel-Powered auf so einem Kartoffel-Batterie-Dings,
aber im Text dergleichen nicht mehr, was da
aber es war. Aber damit haben wir doch
unsere skurrilen Programmiersprachen
der Sendung gefunden.
Das ist für mich das erste Mal, dass ich Visual Basic
sehe und ich habe mir auch noch nie so richtig
PostScript angeguckt.
Und ich muss sagen, ich habe auch nicht viel
verpasst.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Na gut, okay. Aber dann schreibt er hier,
gibt es eine Zeile, die heißt Print Header.
Die macht dann Standard Out und
dann schreibt sie mit
sieben Standard Out Aufrufen
zeilenweise
den HTTP Header
geil.
Da ist ja der
Bash-HTTP-Client, den ich mal
geschrieben hatte, umfang, äh, einfacher
zu lesen gewesen.
Ja, PostScript ist schon eine geile Sprache.
Hintendran komplett ausgeschrieben
WhiteString.
Äh, WhiteString, genau. WhiteString. Standard-Out,
WhiteString. Ach, Scheiße.
PostScript könnte man schon fast
als esoterisch Programmiersprache klassifizieren,
behaupte ich.
Ist die irgendwie darauf optimiert,
generiert zu werden oder so?
Ja, PostScript ist ja das, was du an den Drucker schickst.
Und der Drucker führt das quasi aus,
ich weiß nicht, ob der Drucker das ausführt oder ob der Drucker
das,
ich will das böse Karbot nicht in den Mund nehmen,
das bekommt, was rauskommt,
wenn du das PostScript ausführst. Da bin ich mir gerade gar nicht sicher.
Aber eins von beiden.
Das Kompilat.
Naja, I hate you.
Nee, aber
dafür ist PostScript ja gedacht.
Das ist ja, glaube ich, auch ein Ding, das, also ich hoffe,
dass es nicht falsch ist, aber ich meine fast, das kommt irgendwie
Apple mit, von guter, alte
Zeit, wo Drucker gerade anfingen,
wie Cups
aus der Zeit mitkommt, aber
das ist ja,
das merkst du ja tatsächlich, wenn du ein größeres
Dokument an den Drucker schickst, dass da
recht viel an
Ort geht. Das ist jetzt sehr gefährliches
Halbwissen. Ich nehme alles zurück, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Da müsste ich das nicht mehr
mit einlesen, was genau da passiert, auf welcher
Ebene da was genau gemacht wird.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich habe mich auch immer gewundert,
warum Drucker nicht einfach irgendwie
große Bitmaps hin und her schicken
anstatt sowas, aber
ich möchte es halt, dass die
die alte Denke
bei Computersystemen war immer, dass du so viel
dort rechnest,
so viel Rechenleistung von deinem
Rechner wie möglich weg
ziehst und
dementsprechend hat der
Drucker deinen Rendering-Code
ausgeführt. Du hast quasi
den Rendering-Code nur zusammengebaut.
Ich glaube, du schickst CSS an den Drucker.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also die meisten HP-Drucker haben eine JavaScript-Engine drin.
Oh, geil.
Weil sich nämlich irgendwann jemand, ich kriege es auch nicht mehr zusammen, so ein Network-Routing-Dings ausgedacht hat, was auf JavaScript basierte.
Da gibt es einen schönen Talk vom Kongress von letztem vorletzten Jahr, wo sie einen HP-Drucker zerlegt haben und reingeschaut haben, was da alles läuft und da lief Spider-Monkey.
Okay.
Oder wartet.
Ziemlich abgefahren. Gut.
Was hast denn du für Pix?
Was habe ich denn für Pix? Na, ich
hatte
hier ein Tool, was ich jetzt,
was es bei mir in meinen VS Code reingeschafft
hat, was ich ganz nett finde, ist
To-Do-Tree
und das gibt mir so eine Toolbar
oder so eine Sidebar
an der Seite, das passt mein
gesamtes Projekt nach To-Dos
und gibt mir dann einfach eine
schicke Übersicht drüber, über die Projekte.
Also ich hatte es dir ja vorhin schon mal gezeigt. Ich kann es vielleicht auch nochmal fix aufmachen.
Naja, aber eigentlich ist es eine ganz gute Übung, wenn ich es dir nicht optisch zeige.
Also ich habe an der Seite in meinem VS Code dann einfach so einen Baum mit einer Checkbox drin.
Und das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, weil du hast sehr viele unterschiedliche Visualisierungen.
Du kannst es entweder nach Ordnern und nach Dateien sortieren.
hast du den Dateibaum einfach und hast einfach nur die Dateien, in denen ein To-Do drin ist und kannst
jede Datei einzeln nochmal auffalten und kriegst da die Auflistung von allen To-Dos
für die Dateien oder du drehst es um und hast alle To-Dos
aufgelistet und der zeigt dir dann das an. Du kannst es dann auch nochmal
untersortieren nach Kategorie To-Do, FixMe, XXX und kannst
noch eigene Sachen angeben. Ist eigentlich ganz schön. Es erschlägt einen bloß bei manchen Projekten
ganz schön. Das klingt nicht falsch auf jeden Fall. Ist auf jeden Fall eine schöne Visualisierung
für To-Dos und es macht gleichzeitig Highlighting von
den To-Dos im Code. Sowas hatte ich schon vorher, da gab es irgendwie
To-Do-Highlighter installiert. Dann taucht in deiner
Code-Ansicht an der Seite in der Scrollbar, hast du immer so ein paar farbige Punkte
für, wo ist der Fehler und wo hast du Änderungen im Code
oder tauchen dann plötzlich auch noch Punkte auf mit, wo sind To-Dos
oder Fix-Mes. Eigentlich ganz geil. Fand ich ganz nett.
Klingt nicht verkehrt auf jeden Fall.
So, und
ich muss
ein Pick von letztem Mal revidieren.
Du, warum das denn?
Ich hatte nämlich einen Double-Pick.
Ich hatte letztes Mal Rustlings
empfohlen als Pick
in Folge 38, den hatte ich aber
bereits in Folge 37 gepickt.
Ist doch egal, kannst du gleich nochmal picken.
Redundant-Pick.
In der letzten Folge hatte ich ja ein bisschen
über LED-Lampen gerantet
und warum
buntes Licht in der Wohnung mit LED-Lampen scheiße aussieht.
Und ich habe ein wunderschönes
YouTube-Video gefunden, was das demonstriert.
Das heißt The Weird World of RGB.
Wo unterschiedliche Experimente gemacht werden.
Der hat dann einfach mit farbigen Lampen so farbige Gegenstände gezeigt.
Und gezeigt, dass die Farben sich halt komplett verändern.
Dadurch, dass du wirklich nur einzelne
Farbbänder
beleuchtest und
bestimmte Objekte, zum Beispiel
ein
roter Stift, irgendwie ganz andere
Farben reflektiert, als du eigentlich denkst.
Also
definitiv anschauenswert.
Darauf bin ich auch eigentlich
nur gekommen, weil ich ein anderes Video gefunden hatte,
darüber, was ist eigentlich Orange?
Nee, warte,
was ist eigentlich Braun?
Braun ist eine seltsame Farbe.
Da ging es darum,
Das auch, aber als Farbe selbst,
wie mischt man Braun? Was ist Braun?
Quasi war die Quintessenz, Braun ist eigentlich
an sich keine Farbe. Braun entsteht eher so aus dem Kontext,
im Kopf. Eigentlich ist Braun eigentlich nur
dunkles Orange.
Okay, das ist spannend.
Ich suche das Video auch nochmal raus und packe das auch noch mit in den Shownotes.
Wahrscheinlich auch von meiner YouTube-History.
Brown. The color is weird. Genau.
Da schmeiße ich das noch mit rein.
Also YouTube-Empfehlung für die Leute, die zu Hause sitzen und sich langweilen
und irgendwie interessante Wissenssachen konsumieren möchten,
die sie noch nicht kennen.
Was ich ja spannend finde, ist wahrscheinlich auch schon alte Nachricht,
aber dass jetzt die Fernsehsender, nicht, dass ich es verifizieren könnte,
weil ich nicht wirklich den Fernseher habe,
aber dass die jetzt ganz viel auf Kinderprogramm umschalten.
Hast du das mitbekommen?
Ja, ich habe gehört, dass viel mehr Sendung mit der Maus ausgestrahlt wird.
Genau, und das habe ich auch gesehen bei einigen YouTubern,
zum Beispiel die Diana von Physics Girl,
die hat auch gestern gepostet,
ich weiß gar nicht, was ich so richtig machen kann,
aber hier ist mal ein Video mit zehn Experimenten,
die ihr mit euren Kindern zu Hause machen könnt,
so für alle Leute, die sich gerade fragen,
wie sie ihre Kinder zu Hause bespaßen.
Sehr cool.
Jo, haben wir noch weitere Picks?
Ja, ich war gerade mit was dran.
Ach so, stimmt. Ich habe noch den Swift
Argument Parser von Apple mit auf die Liste
gepackt. Das ist
einfach nur genau das, wonach es klingt.
Eine Argument Parser Library, jetzt eine
offizielle von Apple Maintained mit.
Aber die hat eine sehr angenehme API
und ich finde die echt gut designt
und deckt viel mit ab.
Und habe die jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal
in ein paar CLI-Projekten mit direkt
eingebaut. Läuft sehr gut.
ist gut.
Nice, ich gucke es mir gerade an.
Hattest du das nicht auch schon letztes Mal erwähnt?
Shit, ich habe extra nachgeschaut, ob ich es erwähnt habe
oder nicht und habe es nicht in den Donuts direkt gefunden.
Na gut, also Swift-Argument-Pause.
Ich kann mich bloß daran erinnern, dass wir uns
kurz über den Namen unterhalten hatten.
Ah, shit, doch, ja, stimmt.
Daran erinnere ich mich jetzt auch.
Nevermind, dann retracte ich das direkt wieder.
Nee, lass es drin, lass es drin.
Jetzt haben wir es einmal erwähnt.
Eine sehr angenehme API, hast du gesagt.
Okay.
Cool. Ich habe noch was anderes gefunden,
heute erst auf Hacker News, und zwar
ein Blogpost, JQ Illustrated Tutorial,
falls ihr JQ kennt. Genau.
Also JQ ist ein wunderbarer
JSON-Parser und Durchsucher,
mit dem man quasi so eine Art SQL auf JSON
ausführen kann.
Heißt ja wahrscheinlich auch JSON-Query, oder?
Das heißt JSON-Query, genau. Und das ist halt leider nicht der Standard von der Syntax her. Es gibt ja auch noch sowas wie JSON-Path oder so. Da unterscheidet es sich so ein bisschen von.
Aber dafür bringen es halt noch so Sachen wie Sort und Unique und noch andere Sachen mit. Du kannst zum Beispiel aus verschachtelten JSON-Dateien kannst du auch alle Pfade linearisieren und sagen, ich habe Personenname und Personalter, wenn du so ein Objekt hast, dann kannst du auch ein anderes Objekt machen, wo du Personenname und Personalter quasi auf einer Zeile jeweils hast.
dass du quasi den gesamten Pfad zu einem Value auf einer Zeile haben kannst, dann hast du zwar sehr viel Redundanz drin, aber hast quasi, das ist schwer zu beschreiben, das sind Sachen, die gehen irgendwie mit JSON, mit JQ, aber man vergisst es auch immer wieder, ich habe es jetzt auch schon wieder vergessen, wie das ging, das Tool kennt leider sehr viel Blackmagic und hier gibt es ein Illustrated JQ Tutorial, das ist ein relativ kurzer Beitrag, das ist mit so ein paar Rezepten versehen,
Aber schaut euch das mal an, ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Ich nutze für sowas eigentlich immer TLDR,
um auf der Command Line die TLDR-Pages anzuschauen,
weil ich die sehr angenehm finde.
Da gibt es auch einen schönen Rust-Klein-Teal-Deal,
den ich dafür immer nutze.
Aber das ist schon das Dritte, oder?
Das gibt ja noch Bro-Pages und Cheats.
Ja, aber Bro-Pages sind irgendwie kaputt gegangen.
Und wenn die nicht ordentlich maintain,
habe ich das Gefühl,
und TLDR finde ich sehr viel angenehmer.
Aber ansonsten ist die Übersicht über die Webseite auch ganz gut.
Und was ich eigentlich gerade noch sagen wollte,
ich meine...
Jetzt noch mal die Pics mit rein.
Mache ich gleich mit hier in die Pics,
hier unten noch ein
TLR-Pages.
Genau, das 99%
meiner Anwendungsfälle für JQ
sind eigentlich, wenn ich irgendwo ein JSON curle,
dass ich da einfach Syntax-Hitleidding drauf bekomme.
Ja, zum Beispiel das.
Aber man kann ja,
das ist ja ein echt mächtiges Tool von dem,
was ich jetzt sehe, das habe ich ja gar nicht so
auf dem Schirm gehabt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, du kannst damit definitiv Sachen suchen.
Ich habe es auch schon benutzt, um
aus irgendwelchen APIs automatisiert Sachen rauszukriegen.
Und das macht es ziemlich geil.
Aber ja, mir fällt jetzt auch gerade der
Use Case dafür nicht mehr ein. Den habe ich auch schon eine Weile nicht mehr gehabt.
Genau.
Ich zähle als letztes noch ConfCo auf.
ConfCo ist ein Conventional Commit Checker und
ChangeLog Generator. Ah, das ist der irgendwo hin, oder? Genau, das ist
das Tool, was man sich installieren kann, wenn man nicht JavaScript installieren
möchte oder Node oder so.
Das funktioniert eigentlich mittlerweile ziemlich gut. Es hat halt nur noch leider keine GitHub Action.
Vielleicht mache ich da mal ein Ticket auf.
Die baust du doch demnächst gleich. Ah ja, das hat dann wieder was mit
Docker-Containern, Publishing zu tun, da scheue ich mich immer so ein bisschen vor.
Jo.
Damit haben wir, glaube ich, gerade einen guten Punkt erreicht, oder? Was meinst du?
Ich denke auch. Zeitlich auch.
Sehr gut. Dann, ich hoffe, ihr habt diesen Podcast
hören können, obwohl ihr nicht einen regelmäßigen Commute auf Arbeit habt
oder durch die Welt jettet oder
vielleicht hört ihr uns gerade beim
Wäsche zusammenlegen oder
beim Wohnungen putzen oder beim
Häkeln. Haltet
auf jeden Fall die Ohren steif,
bleibt gesund
und bleibt daheim.
Bleibt auf jeden Fall
daheim und hört Podcasts.
Genau.
Beste Zeitbeschäftigung.
Schreibt uns mal in unserem Matrix-Channel, wie ihr
mit dem vielen Homeoffice umgeht.
Genau.
Also dann, bis zur nächsten Folge akronomisierbar.
Und der nächste Podcast in eurem Catcher beginnt in...
Drei, zwei...
Ah, shit.
Mach du.
Drei, zwei, eins...